[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 140 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark Randall and I'm here as always
with my colleague Melanie Warwick hey
Melanie how are you doing hey Mark I'm
doing good I've survived next how about
you
yeah it's Monday after next still
getting over it it was a big event lots
of people but it was pretty amazing
lots of recordings we also recorded 17
interviews to write next oh my yeah 17
there's a lot there's a lot it was good
yes it was and we will be sharing a lot
of these interviews over the next couple
months one of those actually being this
week yes so are we talking to you today
we are talking to Maya katha [ __ ] who
is here to talk to us about container
security today and we're doing this
interview specifically because next week
will be Def Con and the big brouhaha
over in Vegas for all the security stuff
definitely on black hat besides Dianna
initiative there's all kinds of stuff
that's happening and that's all week
next week and so we thought let's kick
off prior to that with a little bit of
information around container security
yeah great interview but before we do
that as always we have our cool things
of the week and we're gonna end with the
question of the week and this week's
question might also help to give this to
us which is how do I set up SSL
termination on kubernetes with let's
encrypt yep so we'll be looking into
that but mark what are our cool things
of the week oh my god there are so many
cool things of the week we just had next
we talked about all these last week
right yeah we did so rather than trying
to go through all of them I'm just gonna
link to the blog post that is what a
week 105 announcements from Google cloud
next 18 that's a lot of announcements
that's a lot of announcements it's a
good article
it goes through customers partnerships
chrome stuff AI and machine learning on
Google cloud infrastructure services
application development and data and
analytics services databases IOT
security G sweet stuff some social
impact stuff as well and finally 105th
announcements being that next 2019 will
be April 9th through 11th next year so
if we have less than a year to get ready
for that one yeah so basically by the
time you read this article and go
through all the new announcements that
will be ready for you to go to next next
year exactly yeah typical we also have
links to the keynotes you know fireside
chats and spotlight session
these are all videos that are on YouTube
we also have the links to all sessions
for Google cloud next 18 again also on
YouTube so you can check out any of the
videos about the different sessions that
took place there's several sessions I
said I think mark you said at one point
it was almost around 500 it's something
like that I should actually go confirm
it but yeah I think it's about that many
and then we also wanted to highlight
real quick just from all the people we
talked to I know two things in
particular are coming to mind that I
feel like I heard people very excited
about those were DKE on-prem and edge
cpus so not to say there aren't many
many announcements to be excited about
just those are ones that commonly
bubbled up to the top when we were
talking to different participants and
actually I'll make highlight as well if
you go into the keynotes keynote
fireside chats and spotlight sessions
playlist there's some really great
5-minute and synopses of the keynotes
themselves so if you don't want to sit
around and watch the whole thing for an
hour they are great so you can do that
if you just want a quick summarization
there are some really great little short
videos in there that you can just have a
Warchild
agreed so mark I know we talked about
this last week but I have wanted to ask
you've been at next now three years in a
row yeah before it was called next
because it was call next how did this
one compare to the last two it was
definitely a lot bigger that's an easy
answer and it's interesting like I feel
like when I first started we were doing
events for Google cloud platform at the
time you know before it was called next
I think it was called JCP live I have to
go back and look I mean we were it was
small it was really small a few hundred
people I remember teaching code labs in
a basement like that was sort of the
first thing we did you know way back you
know about three years ago and then from
there we went to you know the pure
building where were several thousand
people to Moscone last year so it was
about ten thousand this year you know
another 100 percent right to 20,000
25,000 people it's kind of amazing and
kind of impressive the amount of
investment that's gone into Google cloud
as a whole over the last three years but
yeah I think this year was great an
absolute blast it was great to see
everyone the only thing that with it
being so big is that I didn't get to
spend as much time with as many people
as I wanted to but yes still it was it
was pretty it was an amazing event like
yeah really amazing it was very
difficult to take in all the things that
were happening that's for sure yeah but
it was wonderful what we were able to
experience one other cool thing of the
week that I want to mention that's not
next related that we didn't mention last
week we have a habit of
not necessarily announcing certain
things on the actual show itself and
just talking about it on Twitter but we
have a new website yes we have an update
to our website we did this two weeks ago
it's like when we hit the million market
we've forgot to mention on the actual
show
that's just so we did an update to the
website if you haven't seen it it's all
beautiful new look please check it out
let us know what you think and if
anything's broken
yes so we can make sure it's fixed but
yeah new website we soft launched it
that's why we didn't tell anybody
that's why soft lunch is off large you
know yeah so far this is the hot launch
is that what it sounds like a plan
anyway
you're testing it all throughout next
which seem like a good idea exactly why
don't we go check with Matt I think
that's a great idea so we're super
excited to have Maya catch her up ski
joining us today product manager
container security Google cloud joining
us here on the next show floor thank you
so much for having me yeah thank you so
much for joining us so great to have you
here yes we wanted to definitely talk to
you because we've got a well we're gonna
be releasing this the week after next
and we've got the reason for that which
is the fact that there's Def Con coming
up the week after that which we'll get
into a little bit more later on wait so
is this the week after next to the week
after next the week after next
okay question being how security people
are so stressed out right now they're
looking at speed up next then I get to
work for like five days and then I have
to go to Vegas anyways yeah so my I
guess let's start out with who are you
what do you do yeah I'm a product
manager on the security team of Google
cloud I've been at Google for almost
three years part of that I was a
management consultant did some work in
security for large healthcare financial
insurance companies and at Google I was
the PM for cloud kms until about
ago when I transitioned over to
container security very cool okay what's
container security yeah that's that's a
great question let's start with like do
we assume people know what a container
is let's go let's go okay so a container
is a simpler way of packaging and some
of your software up to make it more
portable and do better bin packing on
your computer so you rather than having
a VM which is somebody else's or your
hardware and you just kind of care about
the OS up a container you care about
even less than that you just package the
application with binaries and libraries
into a container and then you can run it
on a minimal OS that can be kind of
arbitrary on anywhere in your
environment the idea being you can move
this thing around really easily but it's
kind of hard to manage these things at
scale which is what Google learned you
know more than a decade ago internally
and so internally we created Borg a long
long time ago an externally created
kubernetes about four years ago now and
could be 90s is a way for you to it's a
container orchestration platform it's a
way for you to manage containers in
terms of right sizing them scaling
things up and down load balancing etc
groups of containers so container
security yes yes I'll make a small segue
episode 46 we did an episode on board
with john wilkes so if you want to learn
more about borg go back in here about
history of community right awesome
so we're thinking about container
security at Google in three main pillars
for three main areas the first ones will
call infrastructure security so making
sure that your containers are secured to
develop so this is around configurations
you're putting into kubernetes or
through today's engine things like
secret management networking Identity
and Access Management etc all these
things that you need to have in your
infrastructure for this thing to work
the second area is what we're calling
software supply chain we're making sure
that your containers are secure for your
container images are secured to build
and deploy so how do you know that your
images are free of vulnerabilities how
do you know with dependencies that you
have are that it came out of your build
pipeline etc before you deploy them and
in the third area is what we're calling
container runtime security or making
sure that your contain
are secure at runtime this is around
making sure it's traditional security
operations so if somebody attacks your
container if you have an attempted
container escape etc how do you identify
that you know mitigate it can you get do
forensics after the fact to see what
actually happened in your environment
and then track that so what is different
about securing containers compared to
VMs sure I mean at a high level not a
lot in the sense that like I think
security people are very worried about
this model were like oh I don't know
these containers are I don't know what
kuma Demi's is I don't have to learn all
this new stuff it's not that bad like if
you had a network firewall before you
still need network firewall get an IDs
IPS before you still need one still
denied any management's don't eat secret
management all these things are the same
the plug ability points are a little bit
different I think some of the main
differences though are one is this
minimal OS that I mentioned earlier
compared to a VM you can have a much
smaller host operating system than you
do on a virtual machine and what that
means is if you're doing it right that
thing is tiny and you patch that you
know super regularly it shouldn't have
any vulnerabilities that somebody can
exploit and that actually makes your
overall system safer because you have a
smaller service of attack another major
difference between containers and VMs is
I think one of the the talking points
against containers is people were saying
hey I don't have as good a solution with
containers right I don't have this
hypervisor which I have with VMs that
provide strong isolation security
isolation between my my systems and that
was sort of true until Google released G
Weiser made some other projects in the
open source like Cott tech containers
and Noblet containers that provide
container level are actually pod level
informed 9/8 isolation so one of the the
counter arguments against using
containers from a security point of view
is now one of its strengths that you can
use the same you know strong isolation
at a container level and still have the
bin packing the benefits of using
containers that you that
we're aiming for in the first place does
that mean that we should be running all
our containers under something like gee
visor or is it fine what we're doing now
that's a great question I think gee
visor is meant to be a most purpose
sandbox on an all-purpose sandbox Shoji
visor filters about 150 Commons calls
and it prevents you know process from
writing things that shouldn't run that's
not gonna be perfect for every single
application you're gonna want to run in
your environment that being said we used
you guys are internally at Google to run
some of our services and I'll also kind
of answer not a question that you asked
you've said you know should I run all my
Continuum's into you I'll say should you
run all your things on containers what a
great question mark you know not
necessarily but that's certainly in
Google's model right so the reasons we
can do things like live migration is
because we have work right so we have
these whole packages of things including
your containers would turn inside our
containers and we can move them around
easily and patch the underlying
infrastructure without taking you down
that's that's the beauty of using
something like containers actually I
understand I'm curious what would you
not run in containers I think anything
that has specific hardware dependencies
I would probably not attempt to do right
now at least so if you have some very
very custom stuff on bare metal on Prem
Lake it's okay like not that's not the
first workload I go for and then the
other end of the spectrum is that the
functions write something that's super
simple that it's too heavy weight to
spit up a container don't don't bother
so actually I was also gonna follow up
and say is it also possibly a question
of what trust you have in the software
that you're running like if you're like
this is my software I know where it came
from and I know what it's doing so I'm
like that's okay but if I don't know
where the stuff was coming from then
maybe that's something I put inside jeev
eyes or something like that would that
be fair that's it that's a great point
so every we think of a put software as
and the level of trust that it has is a
continuum right nothing is fully trusted
nothing is fully untrusted this is very
security person messaging but if you you
know more trusted software might be
software that you build might be
software that your developers have
signed et cetera at that time you're
internally and yeah you're probably okay
running one developer software from your
company next to another developer
software that's fine you know shortest
and inside at risk
on the other in the spectrum you're
running some third-party arbitrary code
some plugin that you downloaded from
github that you don't really know what's
in there we have some customers who are
running their customers provided data in
containers and in that particular case I
would be worried not so much about like
a container escape but like around you
know one workload affecting another
workload in terms of resource use so
actually and I think you alluded to this
before as well they're tools that we can
use for candidate a nor security so that
we know like hey this came from out
developers or hey this is the actually
the thing that I was meant to download
and I downloaded it and there wasn't a
problem in somewhere between their stuff
like that yeah so so typically when
you're setting up your environment
you're gonna have a container registry
of some kind you're gonna some where you
put all your images and Google offers
one it's called Google container
registry we're great at naming and
integrates with gke and the idea being
you store all the stuff that you want
there you can you know check things like
the visco through QA and testing all
that before deploy it what we actually
just announce it next is binary
authorization so binary authorization is
a way for you to enforce that the
container images that you deploy are
those that you you authorized that came
out of your pipeline so the main use
case we're going for here is I have a
build pipeline I'm using circle CI
huggbees Jenkins whatever happens to be
and I give that thing a private signing
key it signs that it did in fact build
that image and then I have an admission
controller that enforces does that
signature exist on the image before I
deploy it if the signature does not
exist it will not be deployed so that's
called binary authorization some other
cases you can imagine around that are
things like hey I don't want to deploy
images that have known vulnerabilities I
only wanted appointment just that came
out of my particular repository etc so
you can think about that type of policy
management in that space
you were saying before about G Bazar
where would that play a role in the way
this is built out yeah I think G Weiser
is a great tool for any time you have
untrusted workloads that you want to try
to VIN pack closer together and then if
you also have even trusted workloads
that you think that are still gonna work
fine like to me that seems like a like a
no regret move why wouldn't you want to
do a little bit more work and get a lot
more security under the three areas that
you mentioned in terms of security one
question that comes to mind is like
what's the hardest to be able to to
secure for containers I think we're
seeing people kind of shift from left to
right and not you know the first one
being infrastructure then software's
Apache and then container in time a lot
of developers are still focused right
now on how do I make kubernetes secure
and what are the best practices I follow
there and where we're sort of failing as
a community is that it's so hard for a
developer to understand what they need
to do what I mean by that is I mentioned
I started working on container security
about nine months ago I thought it would
take me like a month or two to figure
out what's going on in the space and I'd
be like yeah yeah then I've got
container security figure it out it'll
be fine and it probably took me four or
five months to sort of get a good handle
on what was going on and I was like oh
man I'm getting old and tired and like
why is this taking me so long I'm not as
good as I used to be this is terrible
and then I went to keep Khan in
Copenhagen this wasn't this past name
and I at that point in time I had a
pretty good understanding what was going
on and so many people came up to me and
said how do I set the network policy you
know what is our back and should I use
that and these are it to me these are
like the basics and container security
and information security and I kind of
hit me was like oh my god this is way
too complicated for anyone and so the
the challenge I think we have right now
is not so much that sure there are areas
that the tooling doesn't even exist yet
or we haven't figured out how to solve
the problem yet but the stuff that we
have built is pretty hard to use for an
average developer or the defaults that
are there aren't great for the
opportunity yet so there's a lot being
done in kubernetes in the open source to
improve that but if you're starting off
from scratch and kind of google
hardening guy and you'll find lots of
different people's opinions as to what
you should do
so what are your opinions actresses but
probably on the container side and on
the kubernetes side as well
on the community side there's a piece of
documentation on the gke site gqo / gk e
/ hardening which is our hardening guide
and it goes through what is hardened -
for you already in GK and what else you
need to do some really basics are hey
you should probably use our back if
you're using kubernetes engine use I am
at the project level and then use our
back at the cluster a namespace level
you set up a network policy so pods can
talk to each other by default within the
cluster that's great if you're
developing that's terrible if you're you
know having super sensitive workload
running next to each other in the same
cluster and then from there just some
things like you know setting a sec comm
profile is a great is a great choice you
can move that using pod security policy
it provides a pretty strong security
default for your containers can you
explain what a sec profile is because I
have vaguely an idea yeah a second
profile is a second secure computing
mode and it puts your container sort of
like in a one-way secure State and I'm
you know doing air quotes here where it
can run a certain set of sis calls and
if it tries to run things like sick
return and accidentally tries to run any
other set of sis calls then it will be
terminated so it's preventing your
container from potentially running
something that would be unsafe there's a
pretty good default out there it's the
docker SEC calm profile blocks about 150
uncommon or rarely used sis calls so and
that should probably work for your
application but test it out obviously
before you deploy it together
I know you've mentioned far back before
but I don't know what our back sorry our
back our back is role based access
control it's a way of thinking about
policy management it's a it's a generic
term for thinking about policy
management in criminais specifically
it's how you bind the access to certain
resources like pods or deployments or
namespaces to individual users and so
you would create a role that has a set
of permissions on a particular resource
for example I can read this pod and then
you would bind that between
the role to a user the idea then you can
change the bindings so if somebody quits
their job tomorrow rather than removing
individual permissions you just remove
the role and then they've lost those
permissions that's great
do you have any tools that you'd
recommend for people to use to automate
security in this space I see I still
have people using some sort of
templating language so terraform is
pretty popular or helm that's typically
the the choice people go with is there
any sort of automated tools for like
just making sure there are nerve
vulnerabilities in my containers is that
a thing yeah so you're probably gonna
look at vulnerabilities in your images
cuz what's pretty cool about containers
versus versus VMS and things is that
rather than changing single lines of
code you actually change that line of
code but then you redeploy the whole
container
she had this enforcement point which is
your deployment point where you see
everything that ends up in your
infrastructure so actually what that
means is you get this very powerful way
of patching your infra which is that if
you just patch your images on a regular
basis you can kind of passively deploy
the patch as containers die it'll grab
this image and get redeployed which is
amazing right which is again good think
back of like how Google does you know
live migration with Borg and like this
is why we can do things like that it's
genius
so specifically how do you patch your
images and how do you know what the
Ville --'tis our Google just announced
Google container registry vulnerability
scanning and that looks at the packages
in your images and the images themselves
maybe that's better way of putting it
that you have stored in GCR but we'll
scan those automatically for known
vulnerabilities from the CVE database
and we'll also rescan when new
vulnerabilities are found or announced
then you can patch those as needed and
when you deploy them to your environment
out of curiosity how does that work like
because you've got this artifact that's
an image and then like how does it know
how to get inside I don't know like it
seems crazy but interesting you
decompose the different layers of the
image so you get a look at all the
packages they're inside them and you
take a hash of the packages and you
compare that against whether those are
known to have that vulnerability
yeah so it's so that's not scanning
notably that's not scanning at the code
level that's not scanning things like
hey did you leave keys in code or did
you have miss configuration etc there's
a ton of third-party solutions in that
space that do provide that functionality
if that's something you want to do so
what's a software supply chain
oh yeah the software's of punching is
that is that middle piece that we were
talking about earlier so how we go from
developing your code to having an image
- making sure your image is free of
vulnerabilities - you know checking that
it meets all your requirements when it's
deployed and then to seeing that that
doesn't change over time so that's you
know what a big piece of that is that
vulnerability scanning piece another
because of that is the binary
authorization basically the
announcements that we've had around next
around container security have been in
that software supply chain area I know
we've already talked a little bit about
resources but is there any additional
places people can go if they wanted to
know more to get involved to do
development and container security sure
there's a couple of links that will put
somewhere on the site they include cloud
Doug will calm slash containers slash
security it's kind of an overview of how
we think about containers at Google
including a lot of the items that I've
talked about today and then I mentioned
specifically the hardening guide for gke
is another really great spot if you're
using gke and want to have further
security than what you that well we
already provide you by default well as I
mentioned early in this podcast that we
are gonna be releasing this the week
before the big brouhaha in Vegas with
black hat and DEF CON and besides can
you tell the audience a little bit about
these conferences that are coming up and
what this whole thing looks like so this
is us comically sometimes called like
security summer camp get-together in
Vegas and it's really hot and we know we
don't really sweet you know August is
not the best time necessarily to go yeah
I was there last year and I don't even
know I think I got sick because you're
going outside from like 40 degrees to
like insides like 50 sorry I speak
Celsius 15 degrees I do the same it's
fun
and is insane so DEFCON and all that
stuff so that there's a blackhat
conference which is a big security
conference a lot of vendor shows a lot
of you know as research and elephants
etc same time as black hat there's
besides Las Vegas which is a alternative
security conference and then at the end
of the week there is Def Con which is
probably one of the more infamous
security conferences a lot of live
hacking you know zero days that are
dropped as part of presentations that
kind of stuff for those who might not
know what is zero days zero day is a
newly discovered vulnerability which is
unpatched a great example be like
Spectre in meltdown when those were were
announced actually maybe they're not
such a great example because Google had
patched them when they're announced
heartbleed heart plane would be a great
example where when it was announced it
was not yet patched in the public domain
and so was immediately exploitable by by
an attacker yeah we did a nice episode
on the specter meltdown I talked a
little bit about why the security
decisions are made in terms of you know
when to share information and trying to
patch it at the appropriate times but
that's great to understand and so how
many years now has it been for you going
to these events it'll be my fourth
DEFCON yeah and what are you most
excited about
it's a crypto privacy village so I've
been quite involved with that village
for a while and it's I'm obviously an
encryption nerd and that's that's the
entire village it's like get a couple
hundred people in a room together
detection yeah I was gonna say what's a
village so the main talk tracks at
DEFCON which are in these giant
convention halls right thousands of
people in the room and even those some
of the best talks you end up lining up
for and still can't get into so villages
are the smaller areas to have specific
conversations on particular topics so
for example last year they had a voting
machine hacking village where some
researchers brought in on
20 or 30 voting machines and just
basically said go for it will write up
everything that you find and send them
to some authorities and see if we can
fix some of the problems that are here
which is pretty close close that wall of
sheep which is all about like packet
capture if you take your real phone with
you to Def Con and have it kind of open
and connect it to something that looks
like it might be a legitimate Wi-Fi
somebody's probably just capturing
everything that you're sending them and
then just playing on a giant screen for
everybody else to see oh that's great so
this is the hazing that happens what
what sensation do you take to go to Def
Con like do you take your proper phone I
used I used to take a burner phone and I
think I got a little bit complacent
right I do take a Chromebook Chromebooks
are great for this kind of scenario
where it's like I need something that I
can wipe if I have any concern
whatsoever would it being compromised
but nothing's ever happened to me well
any tips for anybody who is going for
the first time or any of the people who
you know maybe can't go but they want to
learn more at a later date yeah
definitely go if something you're
interested in it's it's a very
accessible conference if you're having a
bad time or someone's being mean to you
go find one of the goons they wear these
like red shirts and they will help you
navigate the conference and take care of
whatever issues going on I would say go
to some of the villages and find people
who are like-minded and find things are
excited about right if you're new it's
like the lockpick village is a great
place to just go hang out there's a
bunch of tables with blocks you can pick
exactly and all the big rooms all those
talks are recorded so if you miss one of
those it's not really a big deal the
stuff it's in person is the stuff that
your
since the fantastic right for most
conference exactly well great I did want
to mention you have a series of blog
posts on the Google cloud platform blog
too about container security that are
really great we had a series about post
leading up to coop con in May seven blog
posts just about container security and
when I'm networking one on image
security one on image signing when I'm
runtime security from the partners that
we announced in that space one on
isolation there's so many blog posts
pretty good yeah yeah we'll have a link
in the show notes there's a bunch of
stuff in there so it's definitely worth
checking out if you're interested in
this stuff Thank You Maya very much for
coming and joining us today thank you so
much for having me and have fun at Def
Con definitely thank you again Maya for
coming on the podcast and sharing with
us about continuous security before next
week's big security conference yeah it
was really great to have a chat and have
your experience and have your knowledge
come and join us
agreed well Marc how do I set up SSL
termination on kubernetes with let's
encrypt so I'm gonna defer to one of our
teammates on it who is a DBE who works
on Google cloud he has a really great
tutorial on github for installing an
open source project called cert manager
so you get HTTPS certificates from let's
encrypt if you're not familiar with
let's encrypt it's basically a free
service that has programmatic api's
before getting TLS and SSL certs which
is pretty awesome and it's free yes
which is kind of amazing it is worth
noting I find the kind of using I think
a lot of people use certain manager even
though certain manager says hey maybe be
careful about using this in production
because we don't know for its ready yet
I don't let people that use it which is
kind of fun so I give you that proviso
as well but the tutorial also links to
things like cloud flare and backplane
like if you want to actually pay for a
service that's gonna provide us a cell
search for you as well so there's a few
different options there
yeah let's encrypt pretty great it's a
great place to get started and get
playing with this stuff so we'll link to
that article in the show notes sounds
good mark you're gonna be anywhere
anytime soon so I don't know that soon
end of August I will be speaking at PAX
dev talking about iguanas I'll be
hanging out at PAX West afterwards with
all my gaming friends what about
yourself what you up to so on August 6
I'm actually gonna be speaking at the
2018 nuclear innovation boot camp at
Berkeley Oh fancy yeah
that sounds fancy are you speaking about
something particular hey I
what else would I talk about fair enough
that sounds reasonable or machine
learning but
asked me to come and speak to the
students there so that'll be fun awesome
all right Melanie well thank you so much
for joining me for yet another week on
the podcast Thank You Marc
thank you all for listening and we'll
see you all next week
[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 140 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
my dog is coming up here and let me try
that one more time